9 secondes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
9 secondes
c'est le temps que je vous accorde pour
décider de votre sort
[Musique]
E
fonctionnaire je suis à la retraite
cadeau
grâce à ces gens je commence à
comprendre ce qu'est la vraie paix et je
commence à croire
que j'ai enfin trouvé ma place
le mâle qui nous frappe beaucoup
d'autres villes la mafia
ces gens sont un cancer qui ne se
soignent pas
vaut mieux pas vous mêler des affaires
des autres quoi que vous fassiez vos
amis et vous allez le faire ailleurs
c'est une menace un avertissement c'est
une team ex non
je suis en train de comprimer le nerf
médian je suis au niveau 3 je vous
déconseille le niveau 4
vous semblait être un homme qui comprend
la violence
j'aime cet endroit vous ne pouvez pas me
le prendre
je peux prendre tout ce que je veux
la police a trouvé plusieurs cadavres
dans une ferme en Sicile c'est vous
[Musique]
j'ai la tête d'un tueur